hi my name is John Green I wrote a book
called Looking for Alaska I'm going to
talk to the cast of Looking for Alaska
who's that
Alaska young Alaska can y'all talk about
when you first read the book and what
you thought of it yes so we are would
you like to start
I'll start with Christine I really for
the first time in high school and I just
really remember feeling so much less
alone I remember feeling like I could
really relate not only to Alaska but to
kind of each character I feel like you
really put like those thoughts and
feelings onto paper so well you know
going through struggles with with
growing and I just felt really like I
could relate did you think to yourself
like oh I wonder if someday I'll be
Alaska everyone I ever know
never yeah well I'm very glad that you
are thank you I'm really glad I got
there so are we okay I I personally I
didn't know about the story before the
audition so I was a little late to the
party which I actually felt was a good
thing because if I had known the weight
of this project I probably would have
trashed the audition but when I did find
out about it I just got the first
episode I read the first episode and I
just remember thinking this story was
really special and I I was telling a
friend about it and I was like yo I
think I found like my thing never let
the colonel rope and helping him move
he's immune to fatigue his anger is a
renewable energy source and you did make
a commitment I did I still have my day
job anytime so I was like I think I
found the thing like my moment you know
my project and out my friends like so
what it was the cons like his car like
trying to find Alaska some about some
bottle asking like oh my god is he
looking for Alaska I love that book so I
went to Barnes & Noble instantly bought
the book right in like a day and at that
point I was like yo this story is like
unlike anything I've ever read at that
point I knew I needed to be a part of it
for sure okay
well then he and I have a very similar
situation in that you know I also didn't
know about the book
so I went in for the audition so I went
in for the audition and then was very
lucky to you know also get the screen
test and then in between that audition
the screen test I got to read the book
and I did get very overwhelmed because I
realized that I was gonna be a very
special something to hopefully be a part
of I was all her Orlando Florida
attended of dr. Phillips high school you
know some side note about dr. Phillips
high school named after a guy named dr.
Phillips didn't have a PhD or anything
just as an adult changed his name to
doctor and then when I when I did you
know get the good news he said we had we
had booked it I ended up telling I was
directing a play at the time at USC if I
don't and one of the cast members who
was a student there he came up to me he
goes look I don't mean to like weird you
out or anything by telling you this but
I have a friend you know in high school
and she went through a really difficult
time and there was kind of a scare for
all of us and somehow one way or another
she got a hold of this book and that's
the book that really got her through it
got her through that hard time and that
you know hearing that firsthand from
somebody and I had just happened to
mention the title of the series you know
it really struck home for me that's
that's when I really realized that we're
doing something we're doing something
that's number of a very fortunate to be
but part of being tonight that's great
hearing that is really overwhelming and
I'm really grateful I mean you have to
get lucky with the book you know I mean
and I feel like I got really lucky with
that one it's been read so generously by
so many people and I just yeah that
that's really nice to hear and kind of
overwhelming Wow when I was fifteen and
I just remember thinking kind of the
opposite I know you asked first thing
like did she feel like she was Alaska I
really felt like I just connected so
much with the character Pledge
especially and you really memorize last
words yeah
you want to quiz me JFK that's obvious
no oh no those are his last words
probably to a fault even I really just
felt so connected to his thought process
and what he wanted so much out of life
at that moment in his life and it was
something where immediately
I remember reading it and then finding
out that there was a movie version
possibly being made and then desperately
wanting to be part of that and doing
everything I possibly could to try and
then it not working out and then it all
kind of coming back around to this now
and getting to do it as a miniseries to
like it all just really worked out in a
pretty magical way but um but ya know
that was that was really that first
experience and I remember it so vividly
I remember like reading a book in my at
the front room in my house and just like
putting it down and immediately I'm like
I gotta be a part of did you write him a
letter
did ya letter it was a great letter you
yeah I haven't read it I read it when I
um got it now recently back a year ago
now it's really sad actually cuz I was
like oh that's what was going on in my
life at the time and like yeah it really
was so in line with what I think you
know mmm
the character of pudges really has going
on when he starts his journey as well so
yeah it was a really personal letter I
yeah I appreciated very much that you
were willing to share that with me and
and you know when you were cast that was
my first thought was it's just amazing
that you know it's Charlie and he feels
such a connection to Myles and really I
mean I saw all of your audition tapes
and there were so many great actors I
don't want to criticize anyone there
were lots of wonderful actors who tried
out for these roles but I mean yeah you
were all just perfect and I feel like
that you see that in the show like the
sense of camaraderie you have that sense
that you have like what I really wanted
for the story was how much in an insular
environment like that your friends
become your fan
and how and I and and even seeing y'all
on set together for the first time I was
like oh they've got it Thank You her
they're already there I'm still mad at
you for coming that first day on the
first day I know I wasn't nervous I was
nervous until I got there and I started
to see y'all do scenes and then I was
like oh this is this is gonna be really
good I think he was gone by the time I
we got to my scene one of the questions
I wanted to ask you is if it was weird
to play a character who had been inside
of a book for you like if it was weird
to like think about Oh lots of people
have read the story and lots of people
have ideas about this character or if
you felt like nah I understand this
person because from my perspective and I
think I said this to each of you
you know you understood these characters
in ways that I couldn't you know you
understood them deeply and from the
inside and so I was never worried but I
wonder if it was intimidating in any way
for y'all for me it was definitely weird
cuz I was like how did this do put me in
the book I honestly felt like I
understood this character so much and
related so much to the character that it
was shocking I just felt like the role
was written for me in a really weird way
and I don't even know if the kernel was
blacker his race never really played a
factor in my mind when I read the book
but I just felt like I understood this
character his rage his sense of humor I
just really felt like a strong
connection to him it was shocking that
it was written I felt like for me it
probably wasn't but well you were I
think you were four when it came out so
it wasn't written around
[Laughter]
yeah I think I like that away I think
Charlie was actually four nine two
thousand five yeah I was six did you fix
yeah my parents dressed me well I
actually just watched much of home
movies my parents just died anyway
that's imeem I definitely I think
honestly if I didn't care so much about
the story I probably would have had an
easier time with it I was just a fan
like honestly if I weren't a part of
this I would probably be judging the
hell out of us right now like right now
he's like all right they better not a
messed us up yeah I've been trolling yes
so I think that was a big thing like if
if I hadn't been a big fan of it then I
probably wouldn't have cared so much but
yeah I was so scared I thought that way
but really help doing the trip with you
to Alabama that's when I feel like I
kind of let go of all the expectations
and you know things online and yeah well
that's it
right room it's really hard not to hear
stuff online especially because positive
comments don't penetrate no you don't
feel them like people like people give
you good reviews and you're like no no
let's
yeah that and the truth is oh and then
the negative things always feel like
penetrate through yeah yeah I fire it is
yeah that's so true and it's a really
it's a really difficult thing and I
think it would be a very very difficult
thing to go through when you're young I
mean it's one thing for for me you know
I am a middle-aged dad living in
Indianapolis you know most of my sense
of self is formed but I do worry a lot
about young people having to go through
the gauntlet of social media and and
it's very hard because we don't always
think of each other as people when we're
talking online and it's a that's a
bummer
definitely and in some ways I mean
that's you know it's part of what I was
trying to write about is that it is very
hard to imagine other people complexly
to see other people as full humans it's
very easy to romanticize or centralize
them or dehumanize them in various ways
and the consequences of that can really
be catastrophic sorry I didn't mean to
take it down to a really right on and
why even especially now a story like
this so important ya know especially
when it happens to younger people
because I think what you say very sweet
guys yeah
so the book came out as we as we've
talked about a little bit the book came
out in 2005 that was for me three or
four weeks ago but I understand that for
y'all is probably a long time ago
what were some of your favorite parts
about like going back in time and being
able to make something set in a time
that you probably only hazily remember
if at all the clothes clothes yeah music
music
yeah that's that just blows my mind it's
hard to envision a time before cell
phones because it's really like taking
over the way we communicate and deal
with people that was so what you really
just had to be present I felt so much
more present when she's trying to take
in that material yeah that was dope how
kind of worked out like it did perfectly
the environment we shot it and really
reflected I mean and that was I know
something that you talked about when you
first got there is well just in the look
of the location that were you're
shooting in but even just tonally like
you know it was very similar to I think
what hopefully that environment would
have been like at the time and for us as
a cast compared to what these kids would
need I'll be feeling that to school Jay
you had the most I would say extreme
costumes like embodying that that Takumi
fashion well I I actually think that the
the fashion made the character happened
for me because you know it was it was
something where internally I identified
with a lot of things that this this
person might or could have been going
through but you know some of the swag
that was even coming off the page I
didn't I didn't get you know right away
and then I had one fitting with Matthew
ciminelli our cost costume designer and
he put me into just a ton of drop crotch
pants and then all of a sudden I had a
voice and a walk and like everything
just kind of like came together because
of that I never got used to wearing
outfits that cost more than my rent that
was always very uncomfortable for me and
I would like be careful like I always
like lay paper towels down to I sat down
yeah I had the budget the clothing but
yeah
the show is very funny I was surprised
by how much I laughed and how much joy
and laughter there is in the show
there are also some hard parts that left
me sobbing eternal sadness you guys
don't trust me something terrible is
happening so fair no I have a choice
condition and watching that I kept
thinking about y'all as people and I
wonder what it was like and what got you
through the difficult times making this
show I think that something that I've
learned personally is that you know the
the journey of life is is very
repetitive and it's long and there we
ride high crests of you know good waves
joy camaraderie and then and then we
also have low crests and there it we
feel very alone and I think it's it's
easy in those times to feel like this is
the entirety of the rest of my life but
I think if we can remember that the
journey of life kind of happens in this
kind of a rollercoaster wave like way
then it's always been helpful for me to
remind myself oh this is just another
one of those low waves yeah it's so hard
to feel like now is not forever yeah
because when it's when it's happening
and when it's bad it it can you know it
can really take I mean I speak from
experience
I've lived with depression for a lot of
my life and when it's bad it always
feels like forever but now is never
forever and there's there's a Liberian
proverb actually that I think about a
lot no condition is permanent mmm-hmm
and that's true for good conditions
right and it's true for bad conditions
yeah and you know yeah and there is yeah
that's that's what I hope people take
away to is a sense of hope like when I
was writing the book this idea was very
much in my head I just dropped out of
Divinity School so there was a lot of
you know thinking about the the big
questions of meaning
at the time for me and there's this idea
that I found very powerful of radical
hope the idea that like hope is
available to all people at all times no
matter what and and I really do believe
that yeah I mean it I mean to me it just
makes the most sense and when I think
about you know this idea of hope I also
feel like by the end of this story
people will feel like a huge amount of
gratitude towards these characters in
this story because I left that last day
of shooting just felt I left feeling so
hopeful especially after we had been
shooting so much intense stuff by that
last episode I just was left feeling
like these characters in this world
everybody was gonna be ok which to me is
a huge you know reflection of your
writing and Josh and Stephanie people
aren't gonna be left feeling hopeless
after they you know finish the series
which is to me the point of the story we
want to feel uplifted by the time it's
over yeah I really believe like I think
in some ways this makes me a little
old-fashioned but like I really believe
that all true stories are hopeful
stories because I believe that hope is
correct for lack of a better term like I
believe that like hope is the right
response to the human condition not like
easy or cheap Hope which is plentiful
and totally useless right like because
when you need it is when you are in
those really difficult times and the
easy cheap hope never helps them but I
do I and yeah I really really believe
that there is hope even when your brain
tells you there isn't and and you know
you just have to you just have to get
there you just have to reach out for
help you have to stay the course yeah
I really believe that I think there's
something to that I mean what you just
said you reach out reaching out for help
to I mean something that I ended up
thinking about and thinking about this
this project and and our arc take away
from it is that is this thing of really
being able to take ownership of our own
grieving process our own solitude and
loneliness and and just waking up in
those days and just
you know that old Simon and Garfunkle
hello darkness my old friend oh yeah but
just having having that kind of
steadfastness about it just being able
to greet our sadness or mourning or
grieving you know as as a kind of friend
here here you are we're gonna we're
gonna try too long you don't get to
drive sit in the backseat but you know
we're gonna we're gonna walk this path
together yeah I just think it's so
important not to try to do that alone
yeah and sometimes I think especially
you you know you can start to feel
really isolated when you're really sad
or when you feel really distant from
people and that's when it's so important
to reach out to reach out to someone you
trust to reach out to a friend if you
can't think of someone you trust to call
the National Alliance from mental
illness as a hotline I've called it
before and and I'm very very glad that I
did so do you have any questions about
the book that I can answer bearing in
mind that I have not read the book in 15
years and you all know it better than I
do I have one how did you feel cuz there
was there's a shift in I'm being very
selfish there's a shift in how we
handled to Takumi's and journey in in
the series of the posts in the book how
did you feel about that I liked it yeah
yeah I liked it I mean I I don't feel
like a sense of ownership over the
characters yeah maybe because it's been
a long time since the book came out but
I also have tried never to do that
without updations because it's just
inherently different like the the show
is not made out of scratches on a page
and so the choices have to be different
but I yeah I I quite liked how he where
he ended up - how did you feel I felt
great about it okay good I'm glad that
we're hell I'm glad that we're both
satisfied absolutely question sure do
you think that having the kernel be
African American changed the story
anyway for you I think that I think that
it did expand the story in important
ways
and I think it allowed allowed you and
Stephanie and Josh and and the writers
to explore things that aren't explored
in the book and also critically it
allowed the perfect person to be the
colonel which i think is the most you
know the most important thing we you
know we got the IIIi mean that I mean
the there was no one better on earth to
play that role and I'm just glad we got
the right person can y'all see this
blush anyone else no pressure it's not
really about I'm just this I'm just
curious what I having watched the whole
show now what what is one of your
favorite moments there's so many
animatic depression there's so many I
mean and also for me watching it it's
very particular because I'm I kept I
kept saying to Sarah that I feel like
I'm in two time machines right like one
time machine is taking me back to the
year 2000 and I'm living alone in
Chicago and I'm writing in a basement
and I'm heart newly heartbroken and
there's another time machine that's
taking me back to 1994 and I'm in high
school and I'm in Alabama and then
they're so it the whole thing was just
really intense and surreal I guess by
the the night at the barn I thought was
really beautifully shot and the
performances in it are so good and that
was there were many many moments where I
felt like exactly what I imagined when I
was writing in my mind I was seeing in
real life which is so surreal and that
was one that was one of them but there
were lots of them like that like there
were little things that you would say or
that any of you would say and it would
sound so much like I hadn't heard that
you know since I heard it in my head 15
years ago and it would sound so much
like it sounded in my head all those
years ago and it's just surreal I really
appreciate that none of y'all have asked
the co-ed the question that I get and
that I've gotten every day for the last
15 years what happened yeah every day
every single day somebody emails me and
asks me like tell me what happened tell
me what happened think that's such an
important part of the story though that
you don't yeah yeah but you don't an
important part of life and I think it's
important to be honest about that and
not go for the easy answer and when your
heart breaks you have to find a way did
you believe me that's always how I felt
you know I knew from when I started the
story that that us as as readers and
even me as a storyteller we were never
gonna be inside of that car and and one
of the hardest things about adulthood
for me or about life for me over the
last 20 years has been living with big
difficult questions that deserve answers
that will never be answered
and that's it's hard and I it's
something I still struggle with but I
think that sometimes you don't get
answers and you have to find a way to
live anywhere I think it's rare to find
stories that are about but not finding
the answer I feel like so much of the
time you know we hear stories about like
you know there's a very clear question
at the end you get that very satisfying
answer that you've been looking for or
maybe it's the answer that you weren't
looking for but there is that kind of
conclusion and I think that's what's so
rare and that's certainly what made me
fall so deeply in love with the story
was was really how I just feel like
that's such an honest representation of
you know things that I've experienced in
life and and so many people that I know
of really not
and having to be having that be the
answer is that there is no you there is
no answer yeah so was that purposeful
yeah that was the only thing I knew when
I started writing the story was that was
what the story was going to be about
everything else changed over the like
five years that I was writing it but
that that was very constant my last
question is not a question it is a thank
you you all poured so much of yourselves
into this and I felt that every minute
of watching the show and every God that
was giving me a most moment every day of
being on set with you and I am just so
grateful I know that it was not easy and
it just means the world to me so thank
you thank you man you changed our lives
and many people's lives you know so no
thank you goes both ways yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]